the jurogan experience what you don't
hear
only on tucker carlson i don't know how
that happened
is anyone criticizing the pharmaceutical
industry the number one advertiser in
all media is pharmaceutical industry
you will not see so it's you it's cnn
can't criticize
the vaccines because then they're
advertising yeah they get calls
it's built on advertising and
it's easier to discredit someone uh
because
when you say this guy is uh is a
horrible person right
advertisers run away from that [ __ ] they
don't want this is
it has no different than twitter or
youtube it's not really about political
opinions but political opinions
can leverage the advertiser relationship
to get someone cancelled
right that's the mechanism so this has
become so good now and
you know like what are they called
sleeping giants and
media matters and all these types of
groups who organize i mean i even see it
on podcast
index i've got a whole thing tim dillon
sucks you have to get him off he's a
homophobe he's a racist he's a
transphobe
and i'll see that you know five other
guys who have podcasting 2.0 apps they
have
the same the same note now there's no
advertising
so we're all like whatever have you wait
a minute hold on have you really seen
something that says tim dillon's a
homophobe
oh yeah he's gay i'm just telling of
course i'm just you know how crazy that
is
are you asking me if the world has gone
insane joe wrote but the fact that they
want to say that tim dillon's a
homophobe because he makes fun of gay
people he is
actually gay yeah i didn't know that i
don't care
but he's openly gay discusses it all the
time but the point is
it's to leverage this is and this is
okay where this all comes from
ultimately i think is again
the problem money corrupts money is the
root of all evil
and uh right now we're in a position
where the global banking system which is
far from moved from even anything you
and i can really understand
how credit works and how there's 400
trillion dollars worth of
paper that surrounds the bond markets
it's all just
it's an illusion in order to
in order to keep the control
we have to utilize this at every single
moment we have to use it as a wedge for
everything and all of these companies
are nothing more than a part of that
system
they are the the money flows through
everything and it's
most of its advertising base all of
silicon valley is is a hits business
uh instead of caring what what their
users want they want hits
so they'll acquire hits oh this is this
this youtuber's great we're going to
hook them up uh this podcast is great
we're going to give them 60 80 100
million dollars
no offense but it's hits business
they're buying hits not
doing anything more than that and if you
don't play along
you're going to lose your income
overnight so
esg have you heard of this no
environmental
uh second don't have a drink you want to
have a drink i'd love a drink
especially when they get into eating yes
it's too intense no but the esg is
fascinating
bring some glasses in yeah so esg
and this is now something that if you
want to invest in a company
they will on their investor relations
page they'll show you their esg
score esg stands for environmental
social corporate governance
and this is where the woke culture comes
from so they've created this
kind of phony baloney rating system that
says well
if you i'm i'm exaggerating but
if you mentioned that you are you know
have a green agenda
and you and you believe in carbon
credits and you might trade some credit
somewhere then you get a higher score
and therefore you're more investable
and it's very interesting to see how
big investors like insurance company
institutional investors
they are steering away from anything
that does not have the right esg
rating and so in order to uh
have investors continue to be interested
in the stock which is important for the
company for its perception certainly for
the
uh the officers of the company and the
shareholders
uh you have to move this move this along
continuously
and so it's very simple to see why doing
a woke ad
as nike or as any other company um and
and uh pride month is fantastic because
you could and
pride is easy throw up some flags show
the right people transfers whatever
right and then you got a high esg score
and so this is a control mechanism that
is being used
throughout all corporations worldwide
and i don't even think it's stoppable
people are just starting to figure out
what's going on that's where all this is
coming from
nike doesn't give a [ __ ] about black
people that way i don't believe it
they care about their stock price of
course individually there's people who
care there's no doubt about it
but it's driven by esg it is the and so
it kind of started with the dei the
diversity equity inclusion
that has now moved over to um and you
can look it up
sas be sasb that's the board of
standards and statistics for
corporations and they have this formula
how you measure
uh your esg score and if you're really
investable
and it's funny because you'll see like
nike has a 75
score tesla which you think would be
really good 38
because you know not woke enough or elon
you know says the wrong things
so it's actually harder to invest uh for
institution to invest in tesla because
of their low esg score
really huh yeah this is this is
i'm just really learning about this
myself how did you find out about this
esg
stuff ah kidney's brother kidneys do you
remember that joke
no holy [ __ ] you're my age no what is
the joke from i
was a whole joke it's like some moronic
kid in school you know figured it out
and then uh it's like hey how come
you're not a [ __ ] the [ __ ] says uh
kidneys kidneys
oh what it was that doesn't quite work
what was that on
that was your joke that was when i was
in third grade
oh like a joke joke yeah like oh like
two jews walk into a bar that kind of a
joke
yeah only less offensive is that
offensive
well the joke the jews joke is they buy
it two jews walk in a bar and they buy
boom shots yeah that's not so this esg
stuff is really being
utilized to control [ __ ]
society society in general and and
twitter has to adhere to the same thing
and they're using it as a method to
maximize profits because people will
support
companies that are woke because it
aligns with their own personal values so
the companies
i wouldn't say profits i would say
shareholder value okay
that's a little different than profit
why would what is the difference between
profit
well this is so currently if you are a
ceo
and you have a board and everyone has
stock and all your c-suite people and
your important people all have shares
and the way the mechanism works all
right we have the federal reserve
and interest rate is at zero so big
companies can go to any bank or
uh and literally federal reserve as a
bank too and say i need
a hundred billion dollars and they're
going to give it to me for almost zero
percent you know because what we pay on
credit card interest or something that's
not what banks pay they pay almost
nothing
so they get that free money and then
they buy back their stock
buying back their stock makes the price
rise everybody who has stock
wins that has been going on for a long
time
that's that's that's the number one way
of getting really rich in a public
company
apple you know this was the thing when
trump had his repatriation of the money
and and also the uh the corporate tax
cut
the main thing that was a problem and
i'm not sure how they dealt with it was
well you're getting all this
you're bringing this money into the
country uh or you're getting a tax break
we don't want you just using it to
reinvent to buy your own shares
because you buy your own shares you're
only making yourself wealthy off of
actually the backs of the american
people because we didn't get that tax
revenue
and that's the system how it's worked
and now they're just expanding it
into this this mythical esg and you know
it's based on how
how green you are uh you know net zero
aspirations reports wokeness social
justice
and it's also because it's connected to
the idea of being a better person
it's so easy to support i love it
brother look at the ads
and it's one of the rare times where a
corporation will get support
from the general public for for sticking
with because
because we're good people yeah and we
all believe we're good people people are
i love it i want my my lgbtq lgbtqia
plus
in my version there is is h in there yet
just overall horny
can't people just isn't that pansexual
are they in there i i love
i find it so insulting that you know
it's called the lgbtq community it's not
a [ __ ] community
it's just as insulting as the black and
brown community oh what [ __ ] zip code
do i go to to meet some black and brown
community people it's really that to me
is offensive
i hate that but anyway so it's so good
to have that group
and by the way the ls don't like the g's
the g's have problem with the t's i mean
all this
that's a great um uh chappelle bid
actually right right yeah the alphabet
people yeah he's spot on with that
spot on it's not a community but anyway
it's such a it's being abused um
just as uh black lives matter inc not
black lives matter the feeling is good
people
because we're good people we don't want
racism we don't want people hurt we
don't want people
discriminated against but we're being
used like pawns and saying oh well then
do this and go here and say yes to this
and then before you know it you're kind
of
stuck in the system where you're afraid
to say that's not okay
and for me it's as simple as saying i do
not believe in an lgbt
community i believe in people and they
do their own thing
and they love who they love and do what
they want and that's
one thing it's not a [ __ ] community
that you can put together
and say this is what we're doing for
them right
right and i think trans women are the
most abused by corporations now
they're using them everywhere in every
ad and you know just to just to
push and push and push well it's just
because it's in vogue right so this is
something
vogue or esg yeah they latch on to to
but of course what does it stand for
again in environmental
social corporate uh goals a governance
i'm sorry government environmental
social corporate governance
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience